muchas gracias del cambio climático y
también las pandemias son un síntoma del
sobregiro ecológico estamos utilizando
más de lo que la tierra puede generar y
eso es un riesgo al fin no solo
ecológico pero económico
en qué medida podríamos revertir estos
efectos estamos a poco menos de 100 días
de la cob 26 en glasgow y ustedes de sus
desde su organización han promovido que
hoy el día de sobregiro de la tierra
también marquemos el inicio de 100 días
de posibilidades cuáles son esas
posibilidades o soluciones que ustedes
plantean para retrasar este día el
próximo año
hay muchas posibilidades si queremos y
esperar es lo peor porque si esperamos
nos hacemos nosotros un daño no estamos
listo al futuro que podemos prevenir que
es posible estamos poniendo como un
calendario de advent para ir de hoy
hasta con 26 para mostrar lo que podemos
hacer para mover la fecha por ejemplo si
hacemos otras casas mucho más efectivas
térmicamente necesitamos menos energía
así si cortamos
la intensidad de carbono en electricidad
por 50% vamos a ganar 22 días si
cortamos las emisiones de co2 en la
mitad en el mundo vamos a ganar 93 días
entonces hay muchas posibilidades en
cómo transportarnos como calentar cómo
procesar
productos etcétera para bajar
nuestro gusto de naturaleza bueno y
finalmente muy rápidamente le quiero
preguntar por cuáles son esos países que
más consumen y los que menos consumen en
este ranking que ustedes preparan de la
huella de carbono si en los eeuu donde
digo si todos vivieron como nosotros
necesitamos como 5 planetas
vengo de swiss térmicamente hay tres
planetas y todos vivimos como en chile
como dos planetas
pues muchísimas gracias a ustedes mathis
wackernagel de la organización global
footprint network para france24